these NRA guys they did it again ladies
and gentlemen they keep putting out
these ads that in my opinion it seems to
me they're going so over the top with
these things well you know what just
take a look and then we'll knock it out
so they want to ban high-capacity
magazines not with the security that
surrounds the president Congress Mayor
Bloomberg Rockstar CEOs and wealthy big
shots and the madmen
drug cartels and home and baiting
killers we'll still get them from the
same black market that sells drugs
stolen cars and everything else that
criminals buy it's just the rest of us
the law-abiding average people who will
have to defend our family
limited capacity magazines welcome
Silverado
middle-class okay where should we begin
my anger level just went up a little bit
I don't know about you guys you well
even you know seemingly even killed alle
for needs alright where do where do we
start with this ad Dave I mean is this
just crazy over-the-topness there
there's there's a tiny kernel of truth
which is that criminals will continue to
acquire guns no matter what the laws are
we all know that that okay but to equate
me or any person who can make it to a
gun show and by you know a hundred
bullet magazine or whatever with the
people who defend the President and the
Congress and rock stars and whatever
people who have had military training or
sniper training or whatever it's
ridiculous and and and it's I feel like
people now are kind of they're they're
proud about their conceal and carry
permit everyone's really excited to
bring in gun places to like show up at
the movie theater with a gun because
just in case something breaks out
they're gonna turn into you know a
sniper and they're gonna take care of
business which no they're not
has this ever happened before has and I
mean really no you know what did happen
recently right after the Aurora shooting
a guy brought a gun to a screening of a
movie and it fell out of his pocket he
shot himself in the ass shot himself
like this big dumb ass that's what's
gonna happen if you're if like the
best-case scenario is you're gonna shoot
your own ass yeah you know worst case
scenario you're gonna do it wrong and
you're gonna hurt an innocent person
conditions front it's very silly it's
very silly they need they need to they
need to just relax just a tiny bit yeah
Jackie what do you what do you make of
these ads in the NRA and just their
their angle like it's totally like
trying to get the middle class like the
middle class running around guns like
you know I like it I want to see in that
and statistically you know countries
that don't have you know people carrying
around guns so many fewer people are
being shot like that's just evidence
it's like proofs I don't understand
where they're going with all that yeah I
think one of the things that's
interesting here is that they're trying
to compare regular people as if our
defenses should be exactly the same as
the president or the mayor of New York
City as if we are under that kind of
are you walking around during the day
feeling you're under the kind of threat
that President Obama is under do you
feel that angry black man tell me I
can't believe that I don't have like the
gun wielding entourage around me because
you know I'm verified on Twitter got a
de minimis where is like my life you
know you know my ironclad team of my
multi-million dollar guns shooting like
Posse with the whole thing where are
they by the way ladies gentlemen this
whole show was predicated and based
around that Marcellus at some point was
going to say that he was verified
Twitter also verified on Twitter finally
Jackie and I were working areas should
have white guys heavily armed uh-huh
absolutely no you do not agree that blue
check you need it because people want
that check from you it should come with
the blue come with a really sexy arm
yeah looks really good in the armor but
also looks equally good out of armor
yeah I'm paying for that I'm paying for
everything can we get back to the point
here there was a point somewhere the
thing that I don't want to continue to
be the angry black bear but there's a
thing at the very end where they're like
Obama's middle class that actually just
some act a little bit of like racism and
I was just like why does it have to be
Obama Smith went
pathetically done the reverse and
everybody every baby that's born in the
operating room why you come out you get
it done I guess that's what the
Republicans want us to think because
that's our right as Americans we should
be able to have a gun if we want to gun
the the truth is is you've got this
gun-toting class of people who are not
raising their children in the right way
and then their children take out their
irrational anger on other people so
they're the ones that are taking their
unlocked you know guns that are capable
of shooting ten thousand rounds in a
second and going into schools and
shooting their friends or their enemies
or whoever they feel like or they're now
going into preschools and shooting
children because it's not just good
enough to go to high schools anymore and
kill children you have to go to it gets
younger and younger and younger yeah so
if you're gonna talk to me about you
know this ability that you want to have
to get a gun talk to me about what
you're going to do to make sure that
those people that get killed who are
collateral damage don't end up dead
because of your right to have a gun
right it's not it's not Obama's middle
class and faces the problem it is it is
everyone's everything everyone is
contributed to it it is our world right
now that is a dangerous place yeah do
something about it Jackie what do you
think is going on in the NRA meetings
though when they come up with this
because we're pretty one of the things
that I'm really gonna try to do here is
bring on pretty you know well-rounded
people that aren't partisan hacks on
either side and yet anyone that's
watching this has got to be thinking I
mean this is just crazy so what do they
do just need the messaging are they what
are they sitting there what are they
doing there they're just trying to get
the middle class to like really want to
protect themselves with guns and that's
never gonna happen like they're not
gonna be like we need guns to protect
ourselves from rock bands and what rock
bands are like running around with like
guns I've never heard of like Motley
Crue's like I think that was a bit of a
logic jump there but I see what you're
doing alright
Oh